Democratic Party has every intention of
taking over health care and energy but
they're not stopping there they like to
nationalize parenting to both Elizabeth
Warren and Kamel Harris have endorsed
plans for socialized child care in the
United States the rest of the party
won't be far behind because why have
parents raise their own kids when the
state can do it joy Pullman is executive
editor of the Federalist and mother of
five all of them eight or younger and
she joins us tonight Joyce I'm glad you
were able to get together get a break to
come on I love your stuff on the
Federalist thank you joining us so tell
us why we should be skeptical of
socializing daycare well I think there's
two chief reasons and the first one is
that is not what mothers want for their
families and the second one is that that
is not in the best long-term interests
of children so the best research that we
have on child care shows that the more
that little children are away from their
mothers and the longer that they spent
the earlier that they do that and the
longer they spend away from their
mothers the more emotional psychological
and behavior problems that they have
long-term so also mothers themselves
just really want to be with their kids
because they love them and they want to
spend time with them so it's really not
good for the overall health of our
society to be breaking them other baby
bond what we should be doing is doing
everything we can to protect it let me
just make the counter-argument that the
left and and many conservatives make
which is that business demands a higher
labor force participation rate for women
it's good for GDP for moms to leave
their small children outsource
child-rearing to people from foreign
countries and get back to work to serve
global capitalism what do you make of
that art well you know the economy well
the point a whole point of the economy
is to support families right we don't
have families in order to support the
economy we have an economy in order to
support families so what we should be
doing is not putting the short-term
interests of today's businesses you know
first what we should be doing is putting
the long-term health of our society
first it is not good for a society if
more children are committing crimes you
know when they grew up as happened in
Quebec when they implemented a full
government daycare program there
not good for society when children have
more emotional disturbances and they're
more aggressive they're having more
special needs placements and so forth
and so I mean all of that I mean so I
mean what's really again what we really
need to do is think about what's most
sustainable for society and of course
business plays a role in that but it's
not the most important thing so really
quick if every survey shows that most
parents would like to raise their own
kids when they're little anyway mm-hm if
I'm if I was running a political party
that's the first promise I would make to
make an economy that could support a
family on one income so if you want to
no one's forcing anybody but if you want
to you can raise your own kids seems
very simple why is no party doing that
well I think it's because most of the
parties are listening more to pollsters
into the people who create push research
rather than to the people who are
closest to the families and to the
children if you particularly talk to low
income and middle class mothers what
they can say they considered a mark of
luxury and a mark of having finally made
it and feeling stable as a family for
them to be able to devote more of their
time for their family and less of it to
work outside the home so that's
definitely something that mothers are
looking for I mean I'm a mother that's
what I'm looking forward to so beaut
worth my family because we know that
when we are investing and where our
children we are investing in the
long-term health of society and so what
moms like me have to say ought to be
listened to because you know we're
voters and we're also the people who are
shaping the next generation if we're not
there you know those kids are going to
grow up and really have a greater
dependence and need that didn't have to
be there you know if moms were just
allowed to do but you know we're created
to do what you want to do it's totally
right instead all we hear is corporate
propaganda from Elizabeth Warren and the
rest of them sure GDP it's your
obligation joy thank you for pushing
back against that insanity I appreciate
it thanks for having me on